time this morning just for the records I
could ask you to give your name and
position starting Mr Phelan good morning
chair I'm McQueen and I'm General
Secretary of the train drivers Union
thank you good morning I'm Frank World
interim General Secretary of the tssa
thank you yeah good morning Mick Lynch
general secretary at rmt thank you
um my colleagues and I will have a
number of questions for you all this
morning and we'll delve into what is
quite a complex
situation but before we do I just want
to put the session in context uh we're
hearing from yourselves in this part of
the session later we'll be hearing from
Network reel and the real delivery group
and next week we'll be having the real
minister in front of us what I'm hoping
we get out of these sessions is to get
some greater Clarity on where we are
with the dismute and what the prospects
are of a resolution uh sooner rather
than later so before we delve into the
the specific issues can I just ask the
three of you uh in very broad terms
how close are we to having these
disputes resolved on a let's say in a
scale of one to ten whereas one you
remain on different planets ten I can go
out and buy a hat for the wedding where
are we Mr Phelan uh thank you chair I
think you include zero and you're one to
ten and we're near them we're further
away than when we started that's clear
uh Mr Ward
okay Mr Lynch
uh I wouldn't be able to say it depends
on discussions I don't I'm not going to
use a scale but we haven't got an
agreement until we get an agreement
we're not close to it really okay well
that's not as optimistic as I'd hoped
um so our discussions happening at the
moment
no
okay we've been invaded to discussions
tomorrow
yeah discussions are we had a discussion
with network rail yesterday we'll be
having one with
um
RDG rail delivery group for the talks on
Thursday
and can you
see what's up with you Mr Lynch because
you're the seemed to be the most
positive of the three although it's
relative
um where do you see a possible Landing
zone for an agreement is on pay is it on
the wider conditions industry reform
where do you see a possible zone for
coming to an agreement well all of those
issues has to be dealt with our dispute
that we put to the companies is based on
job security so they wanted to make
thousands of redundancies that that may
change to lower thousands or into
hundreds we don't know
that's Network Rail and the talks
we have got an issue about what they're
calling modernization
and there were some aspects of
modernization development of the Railway
and development of
working conditions and terms and
conditions in the tractual elements
and but we're a long way on pay I mean
the inflation rate that we use for this
year is that currently in excess of 14
that's the one that the railway used
the previous offer we had is four the
cumulative inflation for 22 and 23 will
be in excess of 20 percent
we've been offered on the talks eight
percent
uh for those two years so it's less than
half and we've been offered nine percent
by the network rail Which is less than
less than half again but let's not
forget we haven't had a pay rise in many
of these companies for three and four
years
so we are having our wages reduced
spending power at the supermarket and
with the energy companies and everything
else year on year on year and every week
that passes it gets worse
they're also seeking such drastic
changes such as the elimination of
ticket offices in Britain there will be
no under their current proposals which
are sponsored and put forward by the
Department of Transport there will be no
ticket officers
and the last version of the offer that
we had from the talks there will be no
guards either
so these are very Stark choices plus
they want to
dilute all of our contractual terms and
conditions virtually so it's a very
strong challenge for us and even if a
revised package comes forward on that
basis which includes
elements as far as the government wants
to to be addressed and this is
completely directed by the government
in every element
um I don't know if any of our members
will go anywhere near accepting those
proposals there are such profound
changes that they'll be very difficult
for any Union to accept and one of the
previous times I was here we had the p o
chairman and said no he said to us and
said this committee no Union in its
right mind would accept what I want to
propose or would have proposed and we're
in similar territory
uh with the railways at the moment so
The Landing Zone will have to deal with
all of those elements as it's called but
I can't see the landing Zone from here
we'll have to see what the talks say and
I don't know what our members will make
of that when they when they get to read
this stuff in detail
and Mr Ward Union settled uh with one of
the disputes that remain uh that was
with network Braille but you remain in
disputes with the RDG yep from what you
agreed with network real can you see a a
sort of spillover if that's a correct
phrase to reaching a settlement with the
RDG well
with two hookah helmets with network
real one on behalf of management staff
which went and didn't take
um last August and then went about it
General grades and controllers which was
settled in December
um the concern girl members were
addressed in those claims and we we put
both offers to the members and they
voted overwhelmingly to Observer they
were in a totally different situation
with RDG and we talk about talks talks
through the RDG the reality is that we
continue in talks with the RDG and we
get to a stage whereby we think there's
been some progress made they go back to
talk to their pay masters and everything
unfolds and for an office we get a pay
we get an offer to the RDG that for a
new relationship in parts to the talks
that we just concluded
um the offer that was on the table is
significantly different if it would be
settled on with network rail and there's
a network real one form some sort of
template yeah probably does it's
something that we could look at it
there's different parts of the package
that we would have to discuss with RTG
but it does suggest a way forward but
nothing more than that
thank you I will come on to specifically
negotiations with the RDG in a moment
but my final question for the moment uh
Mr fear and you said you were zero in
terms of likelihood of a settlement uh
can you expand on that a little please
yes last week um on late on a Friday
evening leaked to the Press before we
even had a chance to look at it or see
it or open the email was a deal that uh
was sent out contained many of our red
lines many things we hadn't discussed
and actually smashed the enabling
agreement we have because we don't deal
with the idea we don't recognize the RDG
we're working through a group called The
rirg and the three Trade union signed up
to enabling green with them part of that
enabling agreement of course was that
certain parts of the Railway were
excluded from Severance including signal
persons guards and drivers I receive a
deal telling me that there's going to be
no compulsory redundancies still 2024. I
am also the deal told us what our people
would do where we would negotiate and
broke the arrangements within the
enabling agreement about how we would
Cascade any broad brush agreement we
might have made at a national level
um my board my executive committee will
deal with that next Monday and
naturally being questioned all the time
or what my view on that deal is I'm
incredibly open I cannot recommend any
one element of it and it may destroy the
ability to go back to those talks in
future
okay well I will delve into to some of
these points and obviously we've got the
the other side of the table coming to us
and just under an hour's time uh but can
I hand over to Paul if you want to thank
you next question yeah I mean I have to
say it I don't be anybody trying to do
any sort of negotiations right in the
public domain which you guys have to
um but um just in terms of
um I'm going to be directing this
particularly at Mr Lynch and Mr Ward and
in the first and so what are you first
Mr Ward if I can but I want to
understand why you rejected the real
delivery group's initial offer and
um you know you said that it had
contained elements that you'd never been
discussed and then that there was
um a significant point that had been
negotiated
um can you elaborate a little bit more
on that I mean I thank you by the way
for the visual missions that we got
um
drive home
uh wasn't it part of the discussions
that we'd been having recently where the
RDG uh and the the talks that we've been
having uh made some progress
um
when when they came back with a formal
offer in reference to drive going on uh
it just came out of nowhere for for us
uh so much so that Arsenal negotiators
uh when did we start talking about this
and and I was told quite categorically
that we hadn't been talking about at all
there's been no reference at all the
deal no but there are things within
within the offer that not just totally
unacceptable too it's it's a payoff of
four percent for last year on four
percent for this year as as Mr Lynch is
greatly rightly referred inflation for
the real industry is running at 14
and four percent doesn't he will not
help a lot of low paid members the deal
that we've done with network rail
um include was five percent in 2022 and
four percent in 2023 but with a minimum
of 1750 for low paid workers there's no
there's there's no
um bottom uh for low paid workers in the
RDG offer uh we are asked to make
commitments in terms of uh delivering on
the modernizations that refer to uh
within the railway that we will not take
any industrial action before
between
signing off the agreement and April
2024 at the same time we have been given
a commitment that will be no compulsory
redundancies before the 1st of April
2024. so they can come and propose
compulsory redundancies in January 24 an
item in April 24th and we're going to
take any industrial action about it
until after those people have been made
compulsory they've done to left the
industry it's just no acceptable
um and in addition to that there were
offers I think it will be on to improved
terms and conditions
um which and we don't get anything
sorry we don't get anything from the
real delivery group in terms of terms
and conditions and so there's no even a
sweetness for our members as far as
that's concerned uh the network real a
no compulsory redundancy agreement ranty
January
um 2025 clearly members working for
train operating companies are asking why
uh those employees in the rail industry
who work for Network rail they've got no
compulsory redundancy January 25 and
theirs is only April 24 and what plans
their employers might have for them so
it creates a lot of uncertainty it
doesn't address the concerns in regards
to pay and there was nothing else that
would sweeten it as far as our members
were concerned we consult with our
Representatives before we decide what to
do any offer that we get for the
employer and every single one year
representative Stanton is this just
wouldn't watch
so you would be looking
um
in your mouth too much but in terms of
the structure of a deal the way that the
one you've accepted sat with a bias
towards the lower paired employees
getting a slightly higher percentage
that's the sort of thing that could be a
step in the right direction is that a
fair comment I would be a step in the
right direction but would also be a step
in the right direction would be an offer
for management staff and an offer for
controllers which I haven't received yet
we've not received any offer for
management staff and controls and that
is notable that when we've done the
deals we're Network real the first deal
that we settled was for management stuff
that was the first author that we got
and we sat with them and we've not even
had an offer and we've asked repeatedly
for office for both those groups of
staff and we've been told that they
don't have the authority for the DFT to
make is any offer
just going back to the driver only
operation just for a second and you said
that that it just suddenly like brought
into the discussions at a late point I
mean I think any casual Observer of
what's going on in these maybe in the
railways at the moment would be aware
that you know there's pressure from
government and others to come up with
more driver operate a driver-only
operation so I'm a little bit surprised
that it was a surprise if you see what I
mean even if I understand what you're
saying there doesn't seem to be
specifically looked at
um can I just ask one question onto you
or is it something that you just don't
see as being
um feasible at all or is it the fact
that you're worried about the fact that
it's being pushed too comprehensive I
know it's from some of the submissions
that you talk about the the cases where
combine a deal or with a ticketless
station puts all sorts of vulnerability
risks because of the two are there
spaces where you would see the driver
running operation is still practical
though
is it just a normal complete I'm just
trying to understand whether it's it's
about a partial stop or a full stop
who you are because Frank doesn't have
guards
we will not accept driver on the
operation in any company
uh without fight we won't we'll never
sign up to accepting Doo it will never
happen while I'm the general secretary
it will never happen when the as long as
the rnt exists
so it's not very clever in a negotiation
in my opinion and it is the DFT
that have insisted on this not the
executives that are coming in to see you
they'll have to do what they're told
because that's what the contract says
the contracts that these train operators
have with the DFT says one that the
secretary of state is entirely
responsible
for their industrial mandate their
negotiating mandate
two he has to approve a dispute handling
program
and three they will make no
communication with the trade unions
without his prior approval including
writing a business as usual letter so if
I write to
any train operating company they have to
inform the dot within three working days
with what the contents of that letter
and that includes phone calls and
discussions as well according to the
contract so nothing happens in this
industry without the Secretary of State
and the 50 people in the DFT today that
are working on this dispute and what
they call Workforce reforms 50 people
working full-time
besides the politicians
right now so
they insisted right at the end and if
the executives involved in this industry
told you the truth they will have they
will tell you that they knew before they
put that on the table it would be
rejected and Mr William will speak on
his behalf because his two sets of
people on on these trains so it's just
not very bright
I just do that why would you if you're
seeking a solution to a serious
industrial dispute that's high profile
would you wait until a Sunday afternoon
at four o'clock to put nine Clauses into
a document
which weren't in the previous version
it's Daft and it's to me it's sabotage
and they wanted these strikes to go
ahead they knew that going forward with
the imposition of change in network Rail
and doo would provoke a reaction they
got the reaction they let the strikes go
ahead over Christmas they didn't lift
the telephone or lift the finger to get
them off they brought forward stage
managed releases in the last week about
minimum service levels about disruption
and all the rest of it about me and
various other people in the industry all
primed through certain press Outlets
and the whole thing has been completely
stage managed leading up to one of these
um sessions of the trade unions as far
as I can see so it's a deliberate
torpedoing of the talks which could have
developed that's why do I was in there
not not because it would have helped uh
resolve the dispute
okay I'm going to try and stick to the
the question that I asked in the first
place which is about do all because I
know that my colleagues are going to
come back around in in discussions and
questions about the specific of
government intervention or not in the
other the opportunity to go through that
in a little bit more detail then so it
really
um you said there's absolutely nowhere
that any train will run with DOR we will
never accept that we're introduced the
removal of more guards from trains no we
won't accept that
and we won't continue with any talks
that has that as a prerequisite
I'll leave that one there chair okay
thank you Paul Jack thank you chair and
I'm sorry I should have come all right
cheers would you like to know the view
of the train driver's Union okay and
drive around the operation hey apologies
no no no I don't want to cut across you
didn't want to you know go quite simply
I've given evidence to this body before
in the southern dispute opposition
Remains the Same the train drivers who
do it hate it feel it's unsafe we
believe it's inherently unsafe prior to
the pandemic the whole industry was
moving a different direction all the
traveling public all past your focus and
everybody wanted visible presence and a
safe presence in every train we've seen
sexual assaults now Railway increased by
180 percent we had county lines and
drugs we had areas where people refusing
to move without security guards and
trains at certain times tonight
unfortunately Society hasn't got more
polite it hasn't got more safer and
since then also the rail safety and
standards balls is designated that train
drivers and Loan workers so every role
has to be re-evaluated in light of us
being those loan workers so where there
is no staff on stations where there's
nobody in Booking offices and where
there's nobody on trains right we do not
believe it's a safe Railway for the
traveling public but also we do believe
that you need everybody in all those
positions to run a safe Railway and we
will not be supporting Doo if it comes
forward as part of this deal or any
future student future
thank you I'll come to you jack listen
one quick question is there a difference
from your perspective from driver only
operated and Driver controls operated
I.E there is another person on the train
they might not be opening and shutting
the doors no but it's about dispatch
it's about our Victorian infrastructure
it's about DIY was time to delivered at
a time when we three car trains and you
dropped a window light on the side and
you can see back along the length of the
train it wasn't designed for 12 or 13
car trains with 1300 people on and one
body to protect them and if that one
body get injured or has a medical
incident there is nobody to look after
traveling public that was not what DIY
was designed for also Doo initially was
in intensive urban areas where there was
a station every couple of minutes modern
proposals are for Doo everywhere where
maybe 27 30 minutes or even now between
stations where anything can happen to
travel in public and there is no
protection and we cannot support that
but I want to come to Jack but they're
just that's just a slightly different
position that's been taken their
challenge you want to just come back on
that just slightly quickly because just
in the sense that you know you're saying
that it's not a broker for you know the
long big trains but the little ones is
where it was put introduced in the first
place is there therefore not still a
window for some use in certain
environments that's okay I don't believe
so I think the real problem with the
nature of modern society and the dangers
to the traveling public and to the staff
on the railway uh preclude anybody from
working alone
thank you Jack thank you chair and my
questions are mainly to Mr Mr Whelan and
first around
um an offer on paying conditions have
you received an offer from RDG well the
first I knew uh was when my media person
rang me up and said what do you say
about the offer
um if I can go slightly backwards to
explain the chronology it might assist
I've been approached by Mr Montgomery
who we're going to speak to later the
Friday of Christmas week saying can we
meet next week
I'd met Mr Harper and Mr Merriman prior
to that and they said they were going to
put Mr merryman in to facilitate the
talks and we were awaiting that meeting
before we went into further talks
because we thought that was due to core
and we needed to understand the role of
the rail minister in the facilitation of
the talks but also pointing out at that
point in time that unfortunately like
anybody else my negotiating team has a
right to take leave and we had no
availability two of the three and on one
of the team were out of the country and
not available and we couldn't have met
anyway
um I then not surprisingly very quickly
received an email from the rail
ministers Department saying could we
meet and we met on Monday which was the
first available slot for the same reason
that I gave to the negotiators of the
rirg
so to my surprise I did have a text from
Mr Montgomery on the Friday morning and
he was on my list of people to bring
back when I finished my other things I
had to do that day could we talk
um but my first knowledge of the deal
that contained so many red lines and so
many things we hadn't discussed is when
we have been asked by the Press our view
on the deal
I went back through my emails later
after having said I hadn't set the deal
to find out that I had been sent an
email at 15 18.
press release went out 20 minutes later
so in terms of the deal that you've been
offered which aspects of that are
acceptable to your members and which
aspects are not
there was not one line in that deal from
the opening comments to the final uh
full stop that I could recommend because
the deal basically says that we rip up
every dream we have local and National
forever and a day have no right to
negotiate future and it'll be forced
Upon Our members in the talks which was
not what we agreed with in the enabling
agreement what we agreed as joint trade
unions in the enabling agreement that we
would agree at a high level things be
passed down to 15 negotiating groups on
the talks and then they would then
negotiate separately on those items if
they could and if they could then make a
recommendation
um we would then put that to our members
and those different companies
part of the difficulty we have is there
isn't a one-size-fits-all deal I've got
companies because of the
fractionalization of the Railway and the
cutting and carving up of the macro I've
got three sets of drivers on different
conditions in one company
so every deal and every aspect of a deal
may impact upon those terms and
conditions and the ability to do a deal
in a different way
and what would you like to see in a deal
to make it so that it would be near to
what to something that you would accept
I think we're very much getting to the
point whereby after four years without a
payoffer a significant payoffer that we
need a clean payoff to move forward to
get out of the current uh Strife that
we're in let's go back to the table
clean to look it Forward most of what's
contained in that deal there's no
modernization in that deal there is no
reform it is basically a productivity
group hundreds and hundreds of millions
of pounds of productivity for nothing
for a 20 cut in pay and strange enough I
do see the role of trade unions to
protect the standards of living the
people they represent he recognized that
there is a need to modernize certain
terms and conditions
and in the areas where we had to
modernize I think I'm the person that
signed off ATO wonders and pancreas I
think
um both my colleagues have made public
statements about where we've facilitated
modernization before there has been a
major project in the UK in the last 23
years that hasn't happened without the
buy-in and the willingness
of the trade unions we want to grow
Railways I don't want my people dying
because there's no toilets on trains and
using tenor products
I don't want my people using semaphore
signals and going to two site color
lights three color lights with an ATO I
actually want a green Railways at the
center of the Green Revolution that we
decarbonize and we deliver Kyoto Paris
and whatever what we're currently seeing
unfortunately is a modernization it's a
pure productivity grave of a wish list
of all the things that various companies
couldn't achieve in the last two and a
half decades because in many occasions
they couldn't afford them unfortunately
in terms of
um pay increase given that the average
driver salary is more or less double the
average salary in my constituency would
you expect that it's right for my
constituents to have to pay more to fund
these increases to driver salaries I
find in rather intriguing we've done
works with DFC we've done work for the
treasury don't work for the government
I've got 15 different disputes with 15
train operating companies who are
declaring profits and paying dividends
in any other economic organization you
would do your fixed costs including pay
first before you declared any dividends
or any profits and I look around the
industry and I see the high profits of
the roscoes and the Venture capitalists
it seems very much to me that we find
ourselves a very modern Monty pythonist
world whereby you now want the funders
to fund the profits of the shareholders
to keep the private interests within the
industry itself and that isn't going to
happen so I don't think you've answered
that question but anyway in terms of
driver salaries do you not think that
drivers already relatively well paid no
what would you consider to be a fair pay
then in terms well if drivers were on
whatever salary they were within the
Range four years ago I would like like
at least a nice seasons and stand still
you know what sort of figure would you
like and we haven't put a figure on it
we didn't we haven't because that was
also part of the enabling agreement that
it would go down to the various
companies to be discussed because a
one-size-fits-all solution you could
only do a broad brush range of things
for people to discuss that would
facilitate a deal going forward now
we've never put a price on it and
ultimately the opportunity cost of
either the productivity or the High Cost
of Living will be determined by the
people vote on the deal you're trying to
negotiate when you don't even have a
figure of how much you want to accept
I may have a figure in my head but in
negotiation he'd bear it with us today I
haven't shared it with the media haven't
shared it with anybody in the last 12
months or more we're waiting to see what
can be achieved within the negotiations
we have and actually what people are
putting on the table but what was thrown
out to the Press last week and sent To
Us by email wasn't even part of the
discussions that we'd had and where it
had been part discussions many of them
have been red lines so again echoing
what Mr links said people deliberately
scuppered any chance of a deal by
putting out things that had already been
declined
thank you Chuck hey Chris thank you
chairman good morning gentlemen I'd like
to start with um Mr William there for me
um can you just uh tell us are you a
member of the labor party's executive
committee I am
um could you also confirm if you are
chairman of the labor party group of
Affiliated trade unions otherwise known
as tulo it's my proud privilege to be
the chair of the labor affiliate Trade
union sector thank you
um do you receive any direction from the
labor party in all these discussions
unfortunately no I've had no discussions
with anybody we have brief people in the
shadow cabinet on our position as a
trade Union but there has been no direct
discussion or policy in relation to this
dispute coming from the leadership of
the labor party I think it's a matter of
public record my view on MPS and others
attending picket lines which is in
direct opposition to my leader at this
moment in time thank you I understand
that the rmt has attended four meetings
with the department and or the minister
could you just tell us how many meetings
you've attended please with which
minister I've had three in a month
well the minister one of the ministers
for transport how many meetings have you
had with the department for transport
um in recent times
um
never met Mr Schatz in person
in person
um had one meet and greet with Emory
trevelyn and I thought she wasn't there
very long
um met Mr Harper for the first time once
before Christmas and I've met Mr
Merriman the rail Minister twice once
with Mr heart before Christmas and once
the meeting I alluded to earlier this
Monday okay so you you've met DFT twice
I've met the TF2 at all
of Ministers of the DFT
I've met the ministers the question was
had I met the DFC I've not met the DFT
in any capacity there have been members
of the DFT writing down every word I say
when I go into these meetings with the
ministers but they haven't
um spoken they haven't contributed they
haven't asked any questions and we
haven't had any dialogue with them if
that's your question yeah thank you
tell us what's the best offer that
you've received so far from the RDG in
respect of a talk the only offer we
received in four years was the one that
was lead to the Press last Friday
so
um I understand that
um as Leff refused an offer from
merseyrail with a 19 19
pay offer
um could you just tell us why that was
we've done a deal on Mercy well
I don't recollect the 90 offer
so uh so 19 over two years I understand
right so we've done a deal with motor
wrestle we've accepted the deal's gone
out to ballot we were waiting for the
result of that so we've recommended that
deal to our members yeah okay so in
which case you have accepted
I think sometimes I understand people
understand how trade unions work and
you've been a member of two the rail
unions so you know that when an offer is
made it goes to the people that have to
actually do the conditions whatever and
they decide whether it's acceptable or
not so we have a member driven policy
that we don't put any deal out that we
can't recommend
if we can recommend a deal we put it to
the people that have to do it and then
they tell us whether it's viable or not
see that has been that that deal has
been done and you have agreed that offer
for Messi I think the result comes in
next week okay to my knowledge but if
that's incorrect I will come back to you
that's all right and and that's the only
operator that's in the operator you've
accepted an offer from now we've done
deals we're currently done deals in
whole trains quite obviously because
it's the Westminster problem we've done
deals in Wales and Scotland
um
um and we had a number of long-standing
multi-year deals in place we've done
deals with crossrail
so we have done deals
you just um are you interested with any
Freight operators
yes
let's switch ones
sorry which do we represent all the
trade operators I know but I mean you
know they're separate companies yeah so
uh as far as operators we've had above
RPI offers with no strings
yeah I'm just have you accepted any
I would have to go back in the last
couple of years we have done deals with
various Freight operators the actual
content of those deals I can provide to
the committee subsequently no problem
we'll be grateful for that but currently
you're not in dispute with any of the
freight operators no no okay that's fine
um thank you very much
um Frank could I come to you next please
um
band one to four management band one to
four of the network rail you
collectively represent could you just
tell us what the highest salary is
within that band that you collectively
bargain for on behalf of them
no tough to come back to you in Reading
enough I understand that highest salary
to be 190 000 pounds
no they will be the case I mean there
are people and if you just repeat that I
couldn't no maybe we'll be the case but
I would have to go and check it and come
back to you I mean a lot of people know
about real people more than that as well
with bands went before the CEO has paid
well over half a million yeah and could
you just could you just
um confirm you accepted or came out of a
dispute quite early on with that
management ban didn't you yeah we did
yeah could you just tell us why that why
that was
um her mem management members voted to
take industrial action first time ever
in my area collection
um and ultimately when we started
talking we got an offer as is our normal
practice
um we put the offer to the
representatives who believed that it was
worthy of going at the members we put it
to the members and the members voted
overwhelming like they accepted yeah
that's why we committed dispute yeah
thank you very much
um Mick Wheeling can I just come back to
you one final question in October
um last year uh we understand it that
the general secretaries of a number of
trade unions as well as members of The
Shadow cabinet attended a fully funded
visit by the TUC
to go to Spain to meet your counterparts
there to discuss other sorts of issues
you face and in effect get uh
would you would you just confirm for us
whether or not you joined that visit or
any representative of ASDF joined that
visit and no representative was on that
visit thank you very much
um Mick Lynch can I come to you next
briefly
um in December Network rail put an offer
I think to you on behalf of your members
of nine percent over two years
um with a minimum period uh you get
anything last year okay thank you
um with a minimum of 1750 pound uh value
for 2022
um am I writing and saying that those
under who were paid under 35
000 would have in effect had a better
offer than that because of the minimum
threshold
yeah there's what we call an underpin
which is rmt's policy that there should
always be an underpid or some mechanism
that advances the lower paid because
continued percentage increases give them
you know over over evolving period a
worse deal
so that's something we're seeking from
all employers and have been successful
in over 20 years or more in improving
lower paid wages but it's not an offer
of pay
it's an offer
of
uh as the DFT calls it reform
modernization it's a package deal so
it's conditional
on accepting major changes
to a whole range of things would you be
willing to share with us the details of
what that offer has been so we can see
it yes it's in the public domain I think
it's been put on it's on the network
Rail website it's on our website
it's sent to all our members I think
it's broadly available it's quite a long
document there's a there's a document
with it called modernizing maintenance
there's some elements for signalers and
others and station grades as well would
you just confirm to us why the rmt only
gave a period of six days for the
referendum of the last offer rather than
the standard 14 days that you would
typically do well we don't have a
standard we rearrange the referendums in
the way that suits the needs of the of
the dispute so what was happening in
network rail at that time was the
commencement of the change that we
hadn't agreed so they told us that they
were due to go to what local
consultation or second level
consultation on the changes which would
mean
the actual rearrangement of the teams
and the cuts to the jobs that they want
to bring in and the initiation so that's
why well that is the specific we needed
to get the referendum result in
for those changes happened so the Clock
Was set ticking by the company
that said to us we're going to
implement these changes from the 15th of
December
so we needed an answer as to whether it
was found acceptable before that
happened I understand on the 6th of
December an increasing number of groups
of members of the rmt broke the strike
um could you just tell us what
percentage of members did actually break
the strike on those days
we don't have a report of any increase
in uh people breaking the strike we know
that as you've just heard from the tssa
that the managers
and unite and the
white collar and supervisory staff have
gone back to work so they're not on
strike they've been on strike with us
previously
uh picket lines are solid the action
that we have taken has had the same
effects as it has on day one as it is
having in the last week or so
are there any final points you'd like to
to share with us in terms of your
current negotiating position with
network rail
well we continue to talk to network Rail
and it will continue to be a challenge
we you know you're going to hear from
Tim shoveler I spoke to him yesterday
afternoon we were always talking
to these companies to try and work up
solutions to the problems that we've
jointly got
and we'll continue to do that but it
remains a challenge
um the demands that have been made on us
are very difficult for us to accommodate
and ultimately we feel those demands and
the inflation rate means that our
members work is being undervalued by
vast amounts but that is a deliberate
policy
of the government in this country at the
time to lower wages of working people
right across the Spectrum especially
where they have an influence
to make them poorer than they used to be
and I think that's a direct result of
government policy
chairman back to you okay thank you
Gavin yeah thanks so much cheer
um I probably should declare before I
start I'm unencumbered by intuities from
the labor front bench and was proud to
support the the workers at Glasgow
Central last week
um but we move on to the middle of
government in the in the dispute
and
this is during the dispute dispute we've
had three entirely different ministerial
teams
um at the the DFT
I went down I'm gonna start with you Mr
billing what what role the government
what role each of those teams have
played
um in the dispute thus far and what
difference it has been between the
approach of the the three the three
teams if I could I think there's been a
constant interference in the free
collective bargaining process by uh all
the teams
um increasingly this seems to be a
generation of bad faith driven from
behind the scenes we've seen that in
what happened with putting Clauses into
the rmt deal that hadn't been discussed
and the uh I believe the leaking of the
deal to putting the deal out to us last
week I don't believe that's been done
without any discussion because as we
know all anything can come out
discussion has to happen with the DFT
and the relevant minister so this
everything that's happening is We
Believe currently government driven and
we have no way of um affecting that has
there been any improvement with the the
new ministerial team compared to the
previous two selections we've had an
offer
um from Mr Harper then Mr Merriman will
help facilitate future talks uh
unfortunately that's been scuppered by
what happened last Friday because at
this moment in time there is no future
talks for him to facilitate
um we would hope there had been an
ownership role within those talks I
think Mr Merriman made it quite clear
that he is just there to facilitate
meetings and how it would work in future
we we live in hope that will help
Mr World same question to you in terms
of the different approach of
um Mr Sharps was non-existent as far as
we were concerned
um we foresaw difficulties where
2022 pay claim uh as early as December
21 with submitted claims to the majority
of employers
um and get no responses whatsoever and
we repeatedly contacted employers asking
for meetings
um get very little movement from the
employers on that we wrote on a number
of occasions to Mr Sharps and asked them
if he could use his influence to engage
employers before we went and dispute get
no responses whatsoever so as far as we
are concerned it just wasn't there
um but well
Mass Pavilion was it was now really long
enough to make a difference to to be
honest in this
um and to be honest the dispute almost
went any hibernation during the
leadership the touring leadership
campaign so that
that that's that decision over there
much more comment now the current team
is is slightly different they engage
um of a number of maintenance
um with idle Secretary of State or with
the real Minister the
continually offer their user offices to
drive facilitator and agreement however
the evidence that we get from the RTG in
particular is that they will not they
cannot make any agreement without
signing off from the DFT and the
government ministers and consequently
anytime we make any progress it goes
back and then it comes back and it's
it's changed again yeah it was lunch
yeah so well I believe the whole this
whole situation the dispute and all the
elements of it have been conceived in
the DFT
um going back to where Mr Heaton Harris
was the rail Minister under Mr chaps
uh so this is Mr Chef's project if you
like
um and this dispute is his uh bequest to
the rest of us so we've all got to deal
with it with it I believe he's still you
know still involved quite heavily when
when the documents go around Whitehall I
think there's a steer from the business
department uh and that's fine but so but
Mr Harper and Mr
um Merriman are very pleasant to deal
with a much
much better relationship I think would
all say that on a one-to-one and dealing
with even I'm sure with the employers
it's a much
better relationship but I always say
it's about product
um the template has been set by previous
administrations in the DFT
and there is a strong hand of the
treasury on top of all of that about
what's going on and the they say to us
directly that we cannot move very far on
this but in the merits of your own
dispute because what it will say about
health education and every other public
servant that we've got involved with all
the all the issues going on now but it
is you can tell it is because in
scotrail we've made a settlement in
transport for Wales we've all made
settlements merseyrail which is outside
their bounds settlements Tyne and wear
Metro outside the DFT settlements London
transport settlements everywhere where
the dft's hand is not the controlling or
nutilla we have made settlements in this
industry and we've made them in the
private sector as far as I'm concerned
we do still deal with private
engineering companies
even cleaning contractors bus companies
Ferry companies all sorts of people in
transport make settlements with our
unions apart from those ones directly
controlled by the DFT and it's in the
contract
the service contract that they have with
the department for transport gives to
the Secretary of State ultimate power in
the negotiating room even though he's
not there so the the entire project is a
conception of the DFT
you said previously to the committee
that
um Scottish government or Scottish
politicians uh essentially and it's your
impression they want to resolve the
issue and obviously since since end
issues have been resolved
um but politicians don't really want to
exhausted but actually I wonder if you
can maybe elaborate on that but with any
sort of specifics regard to some of the
issues at play where it's driver only
operation or whether it's Sunday working
practices on low compulsory redundancies
Etc what's what's your your take on a
different approach and that obviously
applies to Wales and what have you as
well
yeah although I think it's true in the
devolved um authorities in Mercury
merseyside and those other areas as well
in London they do want to find Solutions
and I think what we get from the DFT is
provocations provocations in language
and also what is
put into the documents but you can also
see it the way that they've run the
railway when there's a network rail
strike they shut Scotland and they shut
large parts of Wales and they choose to
run the parts that connect the the to
England it's quite it's quite cynical
with my view the way that the way they
work it and I know because I've met the
Scottish transport ministers and we
engage with senior people in Department
transport Department transport portfolio
I think it's called in the Welsh
government that they are seething about
the way they're treated they don't get
an input into what is a GB wide
infrastructure that we all need to
connect up our communities and our
economies and they get no say whatsoever
from the DFT it's not a partnership
Arrangement between the transport
ministers or portfolio holders and we
know that the northern Mayors are
absolutely seething about the transport
services they get on non-strike days and
strike days and it seems to me that
there is a
almost a stalinist Obsession that can I
say in the DFT about central control and
you can see that in the contracts
British Rail would never have tolerated
the amount of interference from the
Secretary of State the chairman of
British Rail would have been told to get
on with running that business and be
accountable to bodies like this and the
minister of course and to Parliament
but on a report back basis not an
interference basis the DST is not
allowing the Scottish and Welsh
authorities to have any influence on
this dispute even though they are
completely affected by it sure and as if
our TSA getting into tssa get anything
to add to that I'm conscious I need to
move on to minimum service levels I mean
I think
we've seen the message briefing process
that's gone on through the media and
elsewhere and it can only be happening
from the ministry and the DFT and every
time that happens it happens any ability
to realistically sit down in good
conscious to try and find a way forward
um so to move on to the the introduction
yesterday of the minimum service levels
um
legislation
and given the point that Mr understood
made about the the essentially a point I
mean just in the chamber as well that
evantubeless question transparent can be
able to deliver minimum service levels
at the best of times at the moment
um it's quite something but what's
what's your take what's that as life
take to in this legislation as it stands
quite naturally we have an activity
towards it we will seek to see what
legal Avenues we can take to challenge
it it won't solve the current distribute
Because by the time it comes through
Parliament goes through the Lords and
becomes law and then the various
activities associated with different all
the different companies sitting down in
green separate levels we're an awful
long way away from actually having any
current impact uh what it does do is
exacerbate the current situation but
also I don't see how it can operate
safely I I remember when there was an
actual Thrive against dispute
um we came to as an industry and said we
had to run the whole Railway as we did
normally otherwise it'd be unsafe so if
you're talking about running the railway
partially you've already decided Nash
leave that'd be unsafe to do so we await
events yeah tssa
I heard the minister of selling a curse
over there we've just been as a safety
measure
I would I would invite the committee to
ask the transport Minister if he said
any safety concerns during the process
of this this dispute that would cause
him to believe that social legislation
is actually necessary
well it does it tickles me that they
they will put non-qualified people into
signal boxes to break strikes and
they'll have safety incidents at which
they have every time they have a strike
when managers break the rules and break
their competency basis
but it's the unions that are in danger
in safety it's the attempt to break
strikes that Imports more danger than
anything else and it's an infringement
of civil liberties the right to strike
is is something that any Democratic
Society will have if they want to run
the signaling system on network rail
during a dispute uh in the way that they
will they'll have to get all the signals
to work and they will command them and
conscript them to work if they were
doing that in Putin's Russia or in Iran
or China they would rightly be condemned
conscripting workers to go to work
against their will is an outrage and
that's what this legislation will bring
forward that either we will name them or
the companies will name them or even the
Secretary of State may name individuals
that have to go to work on strike days
how that is democratic and free in a in
a free Society I don't understand and
we'll have to challenge it in every way
that we can and it'll have to be
repealed as soon as there's a change in
government
and very brief quick last question but
um before we move on to the last
question
if you were if if you were to have the
the secretary state in front of you or
the room and stuff what is the one thing
you need for them to advance this
situation
I think we'll be consistent in saying
that it's only the government the rail
Minister that can take the shackles off
the Employers in the negotiations
um I previously reported to you that we
were stunned when we found out that our
employers decided to deal with a
government where they couldn't offer
2.12 percent in Pay we never even got
offered the two percent in the last four
years uh constricting free collective
bargaining and then endangering people
if they dare to have a voice in it later
on it's a very difficult direction for
any society
in the effort from that view area
you see okay thank you the employers
need to be free to negotiate yeah we
maybe we'll be asking that in the next
time we'll probably move on to those
questions but Mike you want to come in
on this point too yes uh to frankfurt's
front Ward first
um he recently accused the Secretary of
State and and a quote with actively
blocking any improvements to a possible
deal
um why do you think this Tory government
would actively block any improvements to
a possible deal
I must have learned to see them and I
think it's I think it's something of
inherited for a previous Secretary of
State for transport this is an agenda
that's been pursued by the government
and it's very much antic Trade union and
we've seen the evidence of that
yesterday I think they've been looking
they've been looking for a particular
disputes that they could hang this this
particular legislation on and it's been
encouraged over the last what nine
months we've gradually worked towards
the situation that we find ourselves in
now
all right thank you thank you thank you
um and really to to make to mcwhelan and
Mick Lynch
um do you feel the Block in the deal and
what are the motives yeah I think they
have dictated what the companies say I
don't think they can even deny that it's
there in law it's in the contract so but
they've got themselves stuck they
thought that the public would hate
the trade unions they thought this would
all go away in June and instead the
reverse has happened that more unions
have joined into campaigns against
poverty
um and whether this is a campaign to
drive poverty into our communities I
believe so last week and in the run-up
to Christmas I think the whole thing has
been choreographed and Stage managed so
that the action went ahead so that these
announcements could be made according to
a timetable starting with Mr suneck on
Tuesday I think and then the
announcements of this the Draconian
anti-trade Union laws this week and
ending with the the choreographed
sessions on Monday
so the whole thing has been uh
pre-arranged it's almost as if there's
been some kind of stage director running
this dispute that's why we couldn't make
any progress Before Christmas Even
though I know the companies wanted to
they wanted to come to us we've
developed proposals and they were not
allowed to by the department for
transport and if anyone says that's not
the case
they are not telling you the truth
and I'll put that on the record they
have stopped the development of
proposals deliberately at every stage in
this dispute
and every time we make a suggestion they
have to go and ask the DFT the 50 people
that are working on this whether they
can make a change to the text or indeed
the principles of the proposals
and it takes weeks every time
it's quite obvious from the chronology
of what's occurred Ico mixed sentiments
but quite simply
our employers know how the rail unions
operate
they know that we here are just the
faces of the trade unions we have
executive committees and Boards who then
decide whether things are viable or
whether they go to our members and the
Very activity of leaking a deal to the
Press last Friday before they had the
opportunity to be properly considered by
the Trade union to articulate a response
back to the industry they knew exactly
what they were doing and they must have
been doing on behest to somebody else
otherwise why would they set up to fail
oh
singling out the
DFT essentially Secretary of State yes
it's hardwired into the into the system
isn't the process the the button lines
of them what's the motivation what what
do they need to do to ensure that
actually there's there's a compromise
there's there's a win-win solution
there's a resolution to this this
dispute what steps do we need to take
and why on Earth for the the drive in it
what's the motivation your assessment
well it's not they're not uh free actors
themselves a deity the treasury has
always run this dispute whether it's
been Mr sunac and his previous
Incarnation and the spending limits and
all the rest of it are they decided to
defund the railway by 2 billion plus 2
billion in London transport we've got
loads of problems over there uh that
have been slightly hidden by the
national dispute but the defunding of
the Railway system in general is at the
bottom of this and there's an attempt to
defund a lot of services
I believe and that's that's what is at
the heart of all of the public sector
disputes at the moment that are not
funded properly and people aren't paid
properly people are getting poorer every
week but that is a deliberate policy to
transfer wealth I believe from working
people to people who have got money
already
it's all part of a a game that's being
played in front of us and this is how it
plays out in detail that's their
motivation
Frank
off Northern yard beyond what I said
earlier I think the whole thing's been
choreographed in order to allow what I'm
just further business secretary stand up
and say we're going to count down in
trade unions
that's some motivation
it does appear ideological
um I hear stories from the government
about what skilled high-paid workers and
then their activities across all sectors
not just the rail sector actually seem
to want to challenge vocational people
or people with skills and uh keep them
down
um you know
the fact that we hadn't had a pay rise
for four years we weren't seeking a pay
rise for the two years of the pandemic
we only went to Mr Eaton Harris when
inflation started going through the roof
and when it hit 5.2 now if our members
were demanding a a pay rise not having
had one for the previous two years when
inflation was 5.2 how do you feel when
they find last year in flesh going to 14
and in massive double digits and
possibly going higher than 14 this year
the idea that four percent of four
percent for every condition that we've
ever had because that's what the current
deal does right a 20 pay cut in real
terms right for no future and no say in
what you can do in the future how could
any Trade union sell that to anybody
they represent I don't understand it
thank you gentlemen
uh Greg thank you
hello thank you
can I
ask you all
from the answers you've given so far it
doesn't seem
that there is an end in sight uh for
this particular dispute so if we just
take that as red
how much longer can
you your members
the entities that are your respective
unions financially sustain this dispute
I've said it repeatedly running for the
Long Haul
our members will do this because it's
their futures for as long as it takes I
rather frequently said in the press the
other day I'd like to see it resolved
before I retire I'm going three years
time I'd like to resolve it tomorrow
quite honestly uh people don't want to
be losing picket lines they don't want
to be on strike and I'd rather go back
to doing my day job or trying to rebuild
this industry rather than where we are
now but
when
people want to take away everything that
you may have generated over 140 years in
one Fell Swoop right and pay you less
than you were getting three or four
years ago for it why would they sign up
to that it's not going to happen is it
but specifically to my question
I understand everything you've said
financially financially sustain this for
an awful long time
and your members and their members
Mr wood
I mean respectfully I would probably
turn the question on its head and ask
how long do you think the DFT can afford
to financially sustain the losses that
um between operating companies in public
will be in current as a consequences
which they are contractually bound to do
given their hand and actually managing
these disputes
um as far as our members are concerned
at some point in their future we are
going to be balancing my members new
tellers at that point in time how long
they're willing to continue with us but
that's really down to our members at
this moment in time they seem to have
the the backbone to continue us for a
long time if necessary we've had some
members out in as many as nine days
three as a consequence of this dispute
so they are suffering in their people
getting some of them are locate workers
we hear a lot about train driver
salaries and some manager salaries being
up at 190 000 bands and that
the
changes which have been brought in
industry are going to force down on the
lower paid workers they say that the
booking offices are going to close
across the country a lot of those
employees uh are getting paid around
twenty thousand pounds a year a four
percent pay off at them is less than 20
pound a week as an increase a four
percent is someone who's only two
hundred thousand or even half a million
in the case of Never Real it makes a big
difference to them but 20 pound a bit
isn't going to help a lot of your
members to address in the financial
uncertainty that they're facing at this
moment in time but they've still got the
backbone to stand up there and say we're
not putting up anymore
okay I'm going to come back on one point
you made two or three of you in a minute
but Mr Lynch just on that first question
yeah what yeah wonders of every balloted
all the members 43 000 and they voted
for a further six-month mandate we don't
want to exercise that Monday
we are looking to develop a settlement
and they will decide ultimately
um through a referendum vote whether
that whatever whatever is the final
resolution to the dispute
um we don't Finance our members we give
them some dispute payments which is
money that's collected they don't get
strike pay
so they finance it themselves so they
will make their decisions but at the
moment our action is having the same
effect as it did on day one
and uh we will consider once we've had
all that we've had the discussions with
the government on Monday
we will have the discussions with the
companies and we go to our people when I
have mass meetings of reps all of the
time so we met 400 reps last week
immediately after the action and we will
meet them again
when we get more proposals so we it's
not just a dictat they decide in effect
through their elected people the pursuit
of the dispute what action we should
take when we should take a pause when we
should go back to it when we should have
a referendum so it will be sustained as
long as they they want it to be
sustained Okay so
let's just take as a
possibility that that six-month mandate
goes six months maybe there's a fresh
ballot maybe it goes
longer than that
how much damage do you think from the
existing industrial action
and potential future industrial action
is being done to the railways in the
most generic sense
full stop we know that covid brought
massive damage and that it fundamentally
changed
habits of customers of passengers we're
seeing a lot fewer Rush Hour
use more social use more weekend use of
the railways postcoded
add in uncertainty on the part of
consumers as to whether the train will
even be running because of industrial
action how much damage has been done to
the railway
uh to speak particularly from consumer
Choice which then plays to Mr Ward's
point about losses to the operating
companies as a result not not just with
industrial action but from changed
habits how much damage has actually been
done to the road damage has been done
but as I say the the damage is conceived
and controlled in the department for
transport this is their project they
knew that there would be an industrial
response from the trade unions they
decided to make what they would think is
a Great Leap Forward and provoke the
workforce and attack the workforce so
the damage has been envisaged in
Whitehall by people who know very little
about the railway rather than trying to
get consent and evolution of the Railway
they went for this Great Leap Forward
and it's blown up in their faces so the
damage is being conceived by this
Administration and they are inflicting
the damage they have also brought
forward a set of legislation that they
quickly abandoned
on the future structure of the Railway
maybe they'll come back to that to that
I don't know maybe there'll be a new
transport Minister that'll have another
idea so the damage is being caused by
the inconsistent and Reckless policy of
the people that are in control of the
Railway which is the current
Administration it's not being caused by
the workforce who are prepared to work
through change that is considered and
agreed rather than imposed I I
understand
you wouldn't expect me to agree with it
but you'll understand
[Music]
most people think our rails are in a
terrible space
is useless let me put this into a a
question I understand the perspective
you're coming from but surely you must
agree that by making the railway
uncertain in its operation from the eyes
of the consumer the people who pay talk
about when we're on strike or when we're
not on strike when you're on strike what
about the days when we're not on strike
when it's absolutely useless as well
that's a whole other evidence no so
since the timetable changes okay the
whole thing the question is you must
accept that people are being driven away
from the railway
whether it's running because whether
it's on strike or not people are going
back to their cars they are going to
coaches they are just not traveling here
we've seen the evidence from UK
Hospitality that you know the
hospitality sector took an absolute bath
in December when they're meant to
because people couldn't get into
predominantly
London's fault when you get this driving
people away from the road no you are
your government
right okay Mr Ward
oh I'm in Cleveland if there's
uncertainty about this the the service I
will drive people away
um there's always been uncertainty about
the service in the railway in recent
years for different reasons
um but
Mr Lynch is right it's apologies ask
government that are creating that
uncertainty this dispute has been
prosecuted with the Department of
Transport and they're making this happen
if they took their hands off off the
tiller as far as the employers are
concerned and allowed them in negotiate
with good faith we could find
resolutions to us they wouldn't do that
and the employers can't negotiate with
us in good faith because any attempt in
their part to do so it will effectively
mean that they won't be compensated for
the loss of Revenue uh or for the the
loss of profits that are going are the
foreign profits that are going to
sustain going forward I also think it's
notable actually that despite the fact
that we've come through covert where all
the emergency
Arrangements agreements so I put in
place now all of the companies that were
under that managed to make profits
managed to pay dividends to their
shareholders never gave pay increases to
their workers and no one a situation
whereby in government assume they've got
to cut back and expand the German
Railway the answer is let's get the
workers to pay for it
this is no industrial to the to the
question though the more the railway is
not operational because of industrial
action the less people are going to
choose to use the railways even when
there is not industrial action which is
going to fundamentally undermine the
entire future of the Railway is it not
absolutely and and that seems to be
government policy
Mr Wayland I'm going to reckon my
colleagues so I hope to say in a
slightly different way not to bore you
all
um I'm quite sure we were the
stakeholders that campaigned against the
RPI increasing fairs last year we're the
ones who've um they said that we don't
want the truncated timetables they're
not serving the Northwest and Northeast
where people some people are only
getting one train a day and yeah we've
tried to work within the changing nature
of the industry because it's a seven day
24-hour day industry always has been
um but we had seen football coming back
we had seen demands even from government
departments particularly Jacob Reese
smog that people don't work from home
and we've seen more and more companies
feeling that that wasn't effectively
given the productivity that they wanted
so we've seen a growth in leisure travel
and we've seen the drift back post go
kovid in normal traffic but basically
the railway itself because of how it's
currently operating sustaining on a
daily basis isn't attractive and of
course we're going to go into next
January where there's going to be a
further five percent increase in fairs
we will see you further increase what we
call transport poverty and people's
ability to afford to travel on our
railways so yeah
but
is the choice for a trade Union when
your employer and the government
delivery deliberately causes dispute not
to react and to do nothing this was a
fully expected political and Industrial
reaction from the Bad actors who set
this up in the first place
the companies decided to sign the new
contracts in the post-pandemic world
knew exactly what they were doing knew
how we organized how we bargained with
them for the last two and a half decades
the government in doing what they did
knew that there was going to be a
reaction from the trade unions I think
what I didn't expect was just us still
to be here six or eight months on but
for many people in this industry this is
existential
and thank you
okay thank you
um Jack you wanted to have a second yeah
thank you chair um this is to what Mr
Lynch said a few moments ago around
reduction of initially around reduction
of funding to the railways you just
suggested around 2 million I know Nao
figures show that the amount of
government funding to the railways has
actually doubled since uh 2015-16 to
2019-20 so where do you get your figures
from
I get it from the employers they told me
they've been asked to reduce their costs
by 2 billion I get it from the London
mayor when I go and meet him and the
commissioner for London transport says
I've been told to reduce my budget by 2
billion that's what the savings are for
you've increased the funding it doesn't
go to our people it goes to these
private sector operators into Network oh
we don't get all the money the pay bill
in the in the railway industry is quite
modest the Staffing is at low level the
government are putting more money in
government is putting money into it
they'll probably all have to put money
into it I would ask why they put money
into the railway and allow Rolling Stock
companies and train operating companies
and network rail subcontractors to
extract billions of pounds of profit
since the 90s straight into people's
pockets into dividends so you're and
you'll do the same with health and all
the rest of it eventually when you get
the opportunity so you'll fund them but
you'll shovel it into the private sector
that's what you've been doing they take
profits they may profit every day during
the pandemic and they've made profit on
every day of these strikes they get
protected against a lot of Revenue and
they've not been affected bottom line
two of the companies are subject to uh
speculators takeovers and one of them
has been taken over during this dispute
there's loads of money in the railway
it's been made by private sector
operators
get portal Brook and all them down here
and ask them what they've done with all
the money you've funded that completely
a minute ago you suggested that the
public are behind you on that that is
not what uh latest figures show it shows
that public support is waning and that
you don't any longer have the support of
the public for these strikes is that
concerning to you it depends which poll
you read I went on Good Morning Britain
the other day with a Richard madeley was
on Attack Mode they did a poll shortly
after that and said there was 75 support
for the rmt so it depends which poll you
read of who's who's winning this what
what was expected in the DFT is it would
have zero support and we'd be back to
work with no strikes by the end of June
once you your friends in the Daily Mail
and the Telegraph and all these other
journals followed me from my house to
the station
invaded my children's Facebook pages and
all the rest of it that we would be
Public Enemies number one we're not
I'm a more popular person than many of
the politicians in this room
unfortunately for the public but it the
fact is that we have got a lot of
support it's difficult to get support
during industrial disputes but if you
ask the public do they sympathize with
people getting a decent pay rise do they
sympathize with the protection of
contracts of employment and conditions
they will say yes it's difficult to keep
get that support going fully during
intense industrial action but there is
Broad support for all the people that
are involved in disputes at this time
and there's very little for the support
for the people that are opposing those
disputes and trying to make you
concerned about the increasing number of
your members who are now turning out
during strike days and turning up to
work well we don't have those we don't
have reports that's what we would call
propaganda that we've been told that
these are actual figures so figures from
who figures from Network rails are
showing that increasing
of members of your unions now because
from Network probably turning up to work
how do they know they're members of our
Union
well I mean the the protected
characteristic there are more people
professional protective characteristics
but how do they know they're members of
my year were previously but how do they
know they remember
one Union is settled sorry one Union is
settled
there are 43 000 people work for Network
rail 21 000 of them are members of my
union
though
it isn't concerning to you then that
more we don't have those reports where I
get reports from picket lines all over
the country that they are well uh
attended and that the action we take is
having the same effect as it did on day
one
thank you if I could contribute chair
Mike briefly yes Harry Paul said we're
100 solid
what we are intrigued at of course is
that on the non-strike days are the
great groups being paid to drive trains
and setting the new rate to pay for the
industry so on top of the higher pay
than we get they get 500 pound a day and
then in the arm I believe in one of Miss
Montgomery's companies they're getting
300 pound a day on non-strike days of
driving trains uh when we're not in
dispute with them so if that's going to
set the tone and the level what people
should be paid in this uh negotiation it
will come increasing interesting
you kind of articulated the problem with
the percentage increase of moments ago
when you compared the the wages of a of
a ticket office of staff to a senior
manager you're all very experienced
Trade union so I don't know whether you
saw the um article by two veteran
government negotiators Joe Haynes and uh
Bernard Donahue on Friday at the Times
suggesting that a flat rate cash payment
reflecting the increase in the cost of
living for everybody might be a way to
address the pay issue in this dispute is
that the tool feasible in your view just
very brief I just yes or no answers
would do well there's an element that in
one of the offers that we've got and
we're not averse to any sensible
proposal we're consider it depends you
know what it is but the format doesn't
particularly bother me we'll we'll see
whether it matches up to the problem or
not
coming would give you consideration to
any offer put a dent in the cost of
living crisis we'd be obliged to
right
so we settled the pay claim for our own
staff this year I actually believe it or
not
um we would consider it yeah
thank you okay gentlemen thank you very
much uh for your time this morning
slightly overrun but we've had a good
airing of the issues you're very welcome
to stay for the the second panel if you
wish uh we'll be putting some of the
points raised uh to them but for now
thank you for your time
and then like the the next panelists uh
to come forward
they should do government I think it
says they should do what Joe Haynes and
Bernardino
minimum flat rate of 17.50
on top
so they have almost done now
thank you
um for the purposes of our records I
could invite you to give your name and
position please start with Mr Montgomery
okay Stephen gummy I'm the managing
director of force Rail and also chair of
the real delivery group okay good
morning my name is Tim shoveler I'm
managing director for Network rails
Northwestern central region but for the
last 18 months or so I've been leading
also in terms of the negotiations around
reform
thank you
um you were sitting in the the back row
for the uh first panel of uh Witnesses
um can I start by putting the the same
question I put to the uh to the Trade
union Representatives
um and that is on us just to get a broad
sense of where you see things are on a
scale of one to ten how close do you
think we are to getting a a resolution
to this one being
nowhere near 10 being very close and I
think I think the challenges depending
what Trade union you're speaking about
so if I take three trade unions that are
represented it earlier rmt I believe
that we have an opportunity to try and
move forward so I think we're Within
reasonable areas of where I think we can
get a deal but we have to work through
it with them obviously as it was
indicated there's further discussions
tomorrow and so obviously we wait and
see the outcome of that tssa in a very
similar position where we'll get further
discussions tomorrow as lab is slightly
different where we have been further
behind with our slave obviously we made
the offer last Friday we've heard the
reaction of of asliv we need to do more
work with them and try and get back
around the table so that one is probably
further behind the other twos at this
moment thank you I'll come back on the
the aslift point in a moment but Tim
firstly you know where do you see things
from Network rails perspective yes sir
there has been further progress and of
course in December we made the revised
offer so
um you know attend for the tssa and
unite which which are part of the same
negotiating group for because they're
resolved and and that's good news and
then there's I've never had that money
for the controller's grade group and and
as soon as we can resolve with rmt then
you know then that will resolve those
two unions for rmt we 36 of their
members that are network employees voted
yes for the deal so we're a bit short of
the 50 that we need
there's a couple of thousand people that
need to change their vote
um so we met again with uh with the rmt
leadership yesterday for discussions and
we're planning to meet again next week
um so you know I'm I I'd place that to
seven
so you're you're more optimistic uh than
we've just heard from uh the trade
unions that this can be resolved well
particularly from the network rail
disputes with the rmt because that's the
only one that's outstanding from our
perspective then yes and I and I based
that on the fact that say 36 have never
rail members of the rmt voted yes for
the deal so we only need another you
know 200 000 people to change their
views from an audience of over 20 000
and actually that deal will then
um you know it is incredible so I think
there's every chance by some very
carefully targeted discussions that's
achieving that for those people that you
you want persuade to to accept the offer
or the is that across the board of the
union members or the in one particular
sector of of the industry yeah so this
is absolutely within the network rail
part of the uh the the population of rmt
membership and there are some specific
areas of the deal that we're going to
focus on and where where we know during
the referendum that took place in
December because that referendum
happened quite quickly there were some
quite complex parts to this deal it does
achieve quite a substantial change and I
think with hindsight it was clear that
there were a number of questions a
number of issues that people had that
weren't fully explained during that
short referendum so that's that's our
approach thank you Mr Montgomery can I
just pick up on the uh that this offer
that was put out to as left last week
which you've heard this morning and in
the Press has provoked quite a an angry
reaction can you just talk me through
why you put out the offer in this way
and perhaps in the expectation that the
the the the the reaction would be what
it's been yeah and the situation with
aslips are indicated earlier we have
been it's not moved along as quickly as
we've wanted to and that's been people's
availability those type of things and
negotiating teams have been speaking to
us live that made this itself available
at certain times but what's been quite
clear through it is trying to put
something down in paper to describe the
wider areas of reform that would require
so as Mr Phil alluded earlier on the
enabling framework agreement that we
started off with at the beginning
beginning had a number of Reform meters
that we looked at and when we talk about
the 2 billion industry shortfall when
the pandemic struck revenues obviously
failed to as low as five percent they've
recovered roughly in the area of 80
percent so that's a two billion pound
shortfall in what we would normally
expect to see in revenue for the
industry so we worked with the trade
unions and how could the industry help
meet that shortfall work together and
looking at areas of where we can
self-help so areas of reform Workforce
being part of that area and those other
areas outside of that are where you know
looking at different capitalization of
projects these type of things so that's
what we've been trying to work with the
trade unions those discussions have
moved at various places rmt probably
happened more engaged in some of the
negotiations as I've been slightly
behind but we have been talking to them
it's not fair to say we haven't been
talked to so when we've been over the
last number that we trying to allow
exactly what it is we're looking for
people have said that we haven't made an
offer we decided that we are going to
make an offer two hours left I tried to
speak with myself Wheeling between
Christmas and New Year he wasn't uh he
was looking to try and have a further
meeting with the minister I then tried
to speak to him last week to turn around
and say look can I have a chat with you
so we can start to talk about some of
this it was unavailable uh tried to
phone him the Friday morning to again
update him on I was going to ask you
something a unfortunately he was tied up
meetings that day and we left it to as
late in the day as we could within
office hours and then we put the offer
out to three of 315 in the afternoon
it's fair to say that you've made
reasonable efforts to engage with azlef
throughout this and the offer that you
put out
last on Friday late afternoon was I
don't want to say point of exasperation
but you I wouldn't say it was a point of
the frustration I think it was to try
and lay out all the areas of reform that
we were needing to doing everything in
one a document that we could then allow
us to use that document to move forward
and you know as a negotiation and that's
what myself and the trade unions and Tim
the trade unions try to do is have that
negotiation so that we can try and flush
out the areas of where an agreement or
disagreement and then try to work
forward with that so that we can get
some form of settlement to get this
dispute off the table so having listened
to what they said uh earlier in this
session watch your next move to to try
and engage with us left too well I think
Mr Mr real and eluded that he has gone
back to his board his exec committee
they will look at that document I
believe it's next week and they will
come back to us after that with a
response to that document or maybe not a
response but they will come back in some
shape or form I would Ace and mice that
they will then turn around and say well
that's acceptable reject it whether they
want again to further talks they
understand it more so that's what we
want to encourage that we have a further
discussion with us live so that we can
try and get through the document in more
detail and then try and work to our
solution to the I think I'm quoting him
accurately when he said there wasn't one
line in it that he could possibly accept
that doesn't sound terribly hopeful so
if that is the reaction and they've
spoken to the executive
what comes next
well again I I think we they have to
take it away they have to read through
it
um I would say that there is a number of
areas of where we can get Common Ground
you know the the thing that we've got to
be quite clear is that we are again
we're not trying to we are not cutting
people's wages you know they're out and
increasing their hours what we're trying
to do is walk within the Frameworks that
we have within the companies so that we
can then get greater productivity that
provides a more punctual and reliable
Railway and that's what we're trying to
order and it makes us more cost
effective than you know these type of
reforms will make a smooth cost
effective less Reliant and rest day
working in these type of areas so that
makes a deal with better we can deliver
that service for customers who let's be
fair through all this process of the big
people who've been most affected and
obviously then staff impacted on the
strike action so we've got to work
together to try and resolve this thank
you that's my questions for no return
next to Jack thank you chair and my
questions are predominantly for Mr
Montgomery and in terms of making an
improved offer to rmt and tssa what has
that improved offer are you planning to
make an improved offer to them
um obviously it's a negotiation and it's
confidential at this moment in time so I
wouldn't like to talk about what we're
going to discuss tomorrow I don't think
that's respectful to the trade unions
and no disrespect to the committee but
you would understand my position I think
it's important that we have that
discussion with the trade unions
tomorrow and try and see if we can get
common ground and move forward with the
deal
what is your understanding of where that
Common Ground might be and how you can
move these negotiations forward
again I would rather tip up and discuss
that with the Trade union try on the
beta and the room here
okay in terms of the uh as life Union
obviously we heard earlier and we heard
from a representative from mcwheelan and
he basically said that he doesn't even
recognize your existence and the
existence of RDG do you think that that
attitude has been helpful
I am I think the the language is is
something we have worked very closely
with the all the trade unions since the
start of the pandemic through the real
Industry Recovery Group we have we have
sat together with cannot with enabling
framework agreements that allowed us to
look at these different areas of reform
so that is a recognition note that as
that body we have been doing the role of
rdgrg gets a bit confused I am the chair
of RDG to use myself as a chair of RDG
to sit and add IRG sorry all these
acronyms uh to try and help facilitate
the discussion between the trade unions
you know myself and Tim as I read it
earlier are very experiential with
people we've got a lot of knowledge of
how the industry Works using that
knowledge to then try and work with the
trade unions to get the best outcome for
passengers is what we're really trying
to look for in particularly during the
pandemic and how we had to deal with
staff and how all the restrictions that
were applied it's been a really really
important forum and we've tried to
continue that Forum to then lead into
the paid discussions that we've had and
looking at the taking the reforms that
we talked about in the real Industry
Recovery Group and try to turn that into
our package you think the approach that
Tesla ever taken could be partly why as
you say they are much further behind in
those negotiations than the other two
unions that you've been negotiating with
yeah I think it's a combination of
things of where you know that we we just
have to get more time in the room and
try and walk through the detail in a bit
more and I think cars lab are are you
know I think why we put the document out
helps that situation that it's more open
than everybody then sees it key areas of
where we believe reform can help Drive
the the funding that we then need to get
through our staff our pay increase so
it's important that we get all these
items on the table and then we can
discuss them with asthma what do you see
now is the next steps of how you're
going to move these negotiations forward
and how long do you think this is going
to take
obviously rdmt tomorrow
um so and tssa tomorrow again depending
how those discussions go we'll then
dictate where we go over the next stage
uh Islip as I say waiting and feedback
from them next week and once we get that
feedback we will try and obviously
re-engage as quickly as we can so that
we can try and debate these areas of
reform and hopefully get to something
that we can move forward quickly but I
do accept that there's a number of
challenges I mean we heard from Mr Lynch
his ballot for a further six months
we've heard from uslov that they are
planning you know up to two three years
uh potentially are you allowed going to
allow it to go on that long hey I I
certainly we don't want to you know we
have been quite clear we want to try and
get resolvement of these disputes it
does take both parties we want to sit
down with our Mt tssn as live to try and
resolve this as quickly as we can this
is hot in the industry you know we've
got to be quite clear that this is
happening industry some of the questions
that were asked earlier
where we are seeing customer confidence
in this industry ebbing away every day
we see it when strikes happen the
disruption with the action shot of
strikes where people don't become
available to cover tons at short notice
these things are all impacting and
customers are starting to use other
modes of Transport so we've got yourself
with the trade unions we've got you
trying
get ourselves sorted out so that we can
then start to provide our service to our
customers so that's really important
that where I can have really focused on
is getting the Distributors resolved as
quickly as we can so that we can then
restore the services
thank you okay thank you uh great thanks
very much chair
um so some of the areas we've already
covered our good morning gentlemen
footage just to just to um in relation
to the answer left offer
um um you know I think you were in for
the earliest session but um in relation
to the offer that was made on the Friday
um mcwhelan did explain to the committee
because of the fragmented nature of the
rail industry he's dealing with various
bargaining units in Scotland in Wales uh
mersey rail uh and and so on so I think
it's understandable there are many time
pressures that's even without the
freight side of things where their
disputes have been resolved that that
perhaps he isn't instantly available but
it does seem to have caused some angst
at um I'd admit in order the time in
1538 I think he said it was sorry 32 18
15 18 okay is that the balakrasi
they did he did make a um he did make a
comment that he thought it had
undermined good faith in the process to
to make that offer directly to the
members so it's just to point that out
but given that you were in agreement
with the two billion pound
um figure that that um I think most that
mclinge will in fact the whole panel
agreed with in terms of uh reducing
costs
I wonder if it would give give the
committee some insight as to as to how
the modeling works for example that the
plan to close the ticket offices I don't
know if that's Mr shoveler's um area
really how much saving would that bring
about
some of the other elements you know
there's a lot of talk about
um I've heard Mr shover on the TV
talking about the need to improve safety
and to have
um work that's not exposed to risk and
so on but some of the new technologies
the driver only operation will
surely require significant investment in
signaling and so on so how does the cost
modeling reflect in this two billion
pounds worth of them of savings
again
um
I'm hoping into the the mega detail of
it all so the workforce reform areas has
get various packages and we talk about
the the rationalization of tech offices
again I don't know how much money we
will save in that at the moment because
we have to get through our public
consultation document should we go ahead
with it we'd have to go through public
consultation when we complete that
public consultation that then has to be
submitted to the DFT and somebody has to
have pain on whether that booking office
can close uh or whether we can reduce
the errors on it and that's how the
process works at this moment so until
you get through that whole process you
don't actually know how much money you
could potentially save but again just to
be clear and a lot of booking offices we
are not talking about
unstaffing stations this is one point we
need to be quite clear it's about moving
people from out behind the ticket office
window onto platforms even we give a
greater service hopefully to customers
but
you know where do you you want to make
sure that people are there to deal with
more vulnerable individuals those
individuals who we take out from behind
the glass can sell the same types
attacking via the ticket vending
machines or they can help customers get
a ticket if it's a unique thing which is
but one percent of tickets if it's
something unique they can help the
customer out but when they're out from
behind the glass if they see a
vulnerable individual you know
um somebody need an assistance here of a
child on and off a train a wheelchair
assistants they are there then rather
than behind the glass I I I understand
that but surely there must be some
um costings as to what the cost benefits
are to um to I don't know whether you're
using the term repurposing but however
we describe it the closure of the ticket
office is quite a lot how many ticket
offices are we talking about there's
roughly about 990 yeah I think it is we
mentioned in a documentation
I understand that the trade unions are
have submitted a complaint to the
central arbitration committee on the
grounds that you're refusing to disclose
information that relates to the modeling
of costs not just in relation to ticket
offices but in relation to the
anticipated cost reductions of
driver-only operation as well how are
you responding to that hey we're dealing
with it at this current time it's
obviously something it's it's alive so
we are dealing with it at this moment
um we've heard from the trade unions
previously and indeed we've got the real
Minister coming next week but we have
the Secretary of State and giving
evidence to the committee and he's been
quite
um definite and he said uh he told the
committee on the 21st of December I'm
encouraging the trade unions and
employees to get around the table hammer
out that deal on Workforce reform which
delivers some of the financial savings
that can help make a better pay offer
we've heard that really your hands are
tied through the Mandate and the
contract
so what what kind of what kind of
interaction are you having with the
Secretary of State in relation to the
preconditions that are being placed on
you
so obviously government have the overall
funding of the industry uh the contracts
that are low set of protect with our
train operating companies uh we are very
much uh relying and can back to
government and as it was a allergic to
earlier on we have to ensure that we
seek permission before we were to do and
it becomes at this what they call a
disallowable cost but that's why myself
and the negotiating team for the train
operating companies we're trying to do
the centralized framework agreement so
that we can then go to government and
say look we believe that we've
negotiated these areas of reform we
believe it could be worth X Y and Z and
we believe this could result in our pay
increase of whatever rpn because he says
and we want to be able to offer that to
the trade unions and that has obviously
put in and submitted to the DFT and then
either people believe that that is the
case and obviously people have to check
these things and we will get a mandate
back on what we believe is a sensible
offer
I just want to put something I'm
grateful for that response I just want
to put something to you just from
previous evidence sections when we've
had other train operators notably
um northern rail who were the principal
operator in my area and indeed of Auntie
and when we've asked them
um about their view on driver on the
operation
and particularly for Northern rail where
many of the stations including those in
my constituency are unmanned it isn't
something that they think is either
desirable or that the network is
currently formulated and would support
is there is there pressure from your own
membership in relation to this
precondition on accepting driver on the
operation or is this something that's
been specified by the Secretary of State
and the DFT so the the driver only
operation of driver-controlled operation
is something that we have been speaking
to the trade unions about for many many
years as you know that is approximately
45 percent of services that currently
operate driver only operation of driver
controlled operation I'm sorry these two
terminologies are the distinct
difference in a lot of these cases as
that as a second person on the back of
the train that deals with the customers
service element some pure driver on only
operations you might not have a second
person on the trip so what what we've
been talking to the trade unions right
from the outset from the enabling
framework agreement and over many years
driver only operation or driver
controlled operation is not something
new
so these discussions have always
happened and will probably continue to
happen in the future
the key area for us is where can we make
it more reliable and more punctual for
customers the example is we are sitting
at Waterloo we're bringing new train
tenant to a potentially into Southwest
on Railways if we have driver only
operation or driver controlled operation
can we get trained out more punctual
more reliable of disruption in the
network and the the guard that's coming
in that's been delayed could we put that
train out on time and get the the guard
to join the train at another point and
that's a type of areas that flexibility
that we're trying to do but that can
only happen where the infrastructure and
the trains are able to cope with that in
the industry across a lot of the network
is not in that shape yet because the
trains are not capable of doing it so
it's only where the trains and
infrastructure are able to do it and the
trains are equipped to do that important
brought in to do that that we will then
use that type of equipment I might say
my last experience which was last idea
on the little more train from Newcastle
it was lit two and a half hours because
of camera failures on the trip
I'll hand my chair okay thank you uh
Chris yeah thank you Jim good morning
Steve and Tim nice to see you
um Steve I just wanted to briefly ask
you about the DMO dco pointed out gonna
move on to Tim talk about the rmt
negotiations
um just so we're clear on on the whole
sort of dco DDO Doo proposition
um what what sort of percentage there's
a lot of concern I think it's fair to
say that
um from members of the public borne by
what they've heard from what the unions
have had to say that there is a proposal
to make the entire Railway Doo
now I think hearing from what you've
just had to say that's absolutely not
the case but could you just be a little
bit more explicit as to you know the
sort of conversations you're having
about it and maybe what sort of
percentage of the Railway if you can and
put it in those terms
um you're you know potentially seeking
to have conversations about it in that
respect yeah I think we're looking at
the moment as and again just to be clear
even any of the proposals of the
thinking as and and certainly in a lot
of roots is not to have one of the
driver on the train we've always seen a
lot of occasions where we would see a
second person for customer service
Revenue protection so it's not to take
people off the train freely it's a bit
punctuality reliability the trains
themselves the only way that you can
move this forward do the trains are they
fitted to be able to operate with
cameras so that the driver can see all
the doors so at the moment and I don't
have the exact figure of course but at
the moment there's a number of trains
and service that we could probably use
more effectively if future trains are
ordered in with that type of equipment
and infrastructure is capable of coping
with that then we would like to use that
again to drive punctuality and
reliability it has been proven that with
the driver opening and closing the doors
it saves the untrained person having a
runaway for your customers to go and
operate the doors for example the lines
and trains take the Waterloo Weymouth
line Waterloo Exeter line for example
where the trains are not accumulated to
do it the infrastructure does not exist
there is uh no apps
the trains are not equipped and we have
a lot of trends that are not equipped to
to be able to do that at this moment
yeah thank you very much
something there okay I just want to be
clear because you you've told my
colleague there Mr Lauder that there's
no plan to do it on every train but yet
the proposal actually says that the def
that the the driver only operation will
be the default mode on every Train
That's The Proposal you're giving to the
church will the train is equipped to be
able to do it there's a lot of trends
that are not equipped to be able to do
driver only operation is is there is
there that qualification in the in the
agreement yeah and what we are saying is
you know clearly the trade unions
understand that where there is a train
you know a train that was built but I
don't know I'd like to call it in 2000
it doesn't have the the cameras within
the carbs it doesn't have the cameras
outside the doors so you you wouldn't
you know you can you could you couldn't
spend a lot of money and convert the
trend but in these circumstances what
we're saying is where the trains are
currently equipped to be able to do that
all of those new trends brought into
service then we would look to try and
use that facility on the train and again
to drive punctuality in reliability
that's reflected in the agreement
you know the trade unions I don't think
there's any misunderstanding in that
area thank you
Tim I just wanted to come back to you to
ask if you could give us a sort of an
update from your perspective please on
the situation with negotiations with the
rmt as it is today
yep so uh we we met yesterday with the
leadership of the rmt at uh Dempsey
um and we were having discussions
because the you know the the offer that
we made in December is a substantial
offer
as I mentioned earlier has been accepted
by two of the three trade unions so we
wanted to hear from the leadership of
the rmt at their views on why you know
the IMD had been unable to support and
recommend the deal as we'd hoped they
would have done when we made the offer
in December and they sent it out with a
with a recommendation to members to
reject the deal which we know you know
of course some people to vote no and to
understand any other details uh that
they particularly wanted to feed back on
that have been causing concern
um and we were also able to
um suggest some areas where based on our
discussions that we've been having with
our staff members
um some of the feedback that we had
asked the referendum in December where
people said to us look you know this is
this is
um I didn't quite understand this point
or could you explain this to me again or
I've got a question about it as I said
because it was quite a short referendum
and there was a little time to prepare
for it it didn't give time for some of
the materials and some of the briefing I
think we both wanted to do to make sure
that both representatives and managers
could have answered the questions the
genuine questions that our employees had
that process didn't work effectively at
all so what we'd like to do is is is
really understand
um and we have been doing that over this
Christmas period uh and again hearing
from the union yesterday where which of
those areas that we should now
specifically go back to provide further
discussion and confidence for our
employees with the objective of of being
able to have a further referendum at the
right moment do you have any insights
currently as to what those specific
remaining issues are that you know
require resolution yes yes I do um
though I think there are two or three
areas that have become very clear and
based on the feedback we've had from
employees and actually broadly similar
to the things I'm hearing from from the
rmt as well so that allows us to Target
very clearly uh the the things that we
can perhaps find some further guidance
on and some some areas but perhaps we
didn't explain very well and therefore
by doing that better it gives our
employees a better opportunity to down
just how good this deal could be for
them because as we've said you know you
you're aware of the
um the five percent offer that we've
made for 20 22 but as I think as the
trade unions and uh General Secretary of
the tssa agreed you know that comes with
an under an underpin of 1 750 pounds now
for some members uh some of our
employees that run say 30 000 pounds or
less that means the deal's worth over 10
not nine percent over ten percent and
and more the further you go down the pay
scales so this is
um uh especially for the lower paid
members of Staff a valuable deal and of
course it comes with all the other
things we've talked about like the that
the union have asked for like a
guarantee around no compulsory
redundancies until January 2025. uh and
of course the discounted rail travel for
the employee and their dependents which
again is something unions have been
asking for for a long time so there's
other that as well as the cash there's a
number of other elements to this deal
which we think
um recognize the challenge environment
that we're in I recognize the the
economic circumstance and the cost of
living issues and inflation but also so
make it an affordable deal but also
making an attractive deal because we're
trying to look after those who need the
support
you will probably have heard me uh ask
um the General Secretary of the rmt
earlier about how rock solid uh his
members were in The strikes over the
last of um five six weeks or so I just
wondered if you had any insights or
observations that you might be able to
offer in respect to that question I
asked earlier yeah I mean I think you
know the strikes have been underway now
for a very long period of time but we
have absolutely seen in the last uh set
of strikes those just before and then
especially after Christmas so that has
been a return to work by number of
employees both in maintenance and
operations it's very localized it tends
to be groups of people that will come
back in
um rather than individuals on their own
um but nevertheless yes that that is
there's clearly a pattern of that we can
see emotionally
would you say that
um
some employees who are also members of
the rmt in this example and I've in the
situation where they want to come back
to work and maybe the the shortened
referendum period that we saw last month
might not have given them enough time to
properly digest what was on the table
and actually we might be yeah we might
be in a position of real optimism here
absolutely I mean you know I'm
perpetually optimistic because in doing
these type of roles we have to to
despite all of the challenges we have to
keep searching repeatedly for an area
where we have alignment where we have uh
something that we can build on
um so and I think this is a particular
area now that yes it's quite clear that
from from my from the discussions that I
have when I go around
um talking to our to my teams my staff
um what I see from my email inbox and
and contacts that I receive there was a
general feeling from from a lot of
people that before Christmas the
referenda was too short didn't allow
people time to ask the questions they
had
um and yeah I think those those
employees that have come back into work
um you know obviously that's been a
substantial thing for those for those
groups it's not done lightly and it's
not the way that we want to resolve the
dispute either you know it's not we
didn't set out to to break the strike
we've set out to run the train service
safely and reliably
um even on days when the rmt were not at
work
um and we'll continue to do that and
indeed we'll look to you know should
there be more strikes and I said really
hope there are but should there be more
strikes then we we will look to run more
trains next time and because our
capability to do that is growing but our
main effort is to make sure that is to
try and find a way of clarifying those
questions that people have so we can
find a way of resolving them thank you
and just finally Tim from me um it's
clear that you've made a lot of progress
and indeed resolved
um the dispute with the tssa and unite
in terms of the network rails
relationship
um I just wondered if you would like to
briefly share any insights as to why it
may have been quicker or easier
to come to
a settlement with those unions rather
than as you're finding it um not well
you haven't come to that conclusion at
the moment with the rmt yes I mean
there's no doubt that
um the fact that the tssa for example
um recommended to its members to uh vote
Yes for the deal helps because of course
a lot of you know I really feel for our
employees we've all been there actually
it's this is a very confusing times out
there they receive messages from
management they received messages from
unions and understanding the detail of a
deal or a proposal is complex
um so therefore sometimes you know
employers will listen very clearly to
what the union is saying and when the
union suggests yes we think this is a
deal that you should support that
clearly brings with it
um a waiting doesn't it and until they
did and we had a high response a very
positive response from chairs members
um that that was not the case with rmt
we'd hoped that rmt would um support the
deal they weren't able to support the
deal in fact they recommended
to members to to vote no
despite that 36 percent members voted
yes and I think that's quite significant
and that's one of the things that gives
me optimism to think we're on the right
track
thank you very much back to you thank
you Graham did you have any
supplementaries on this point before we
turn into Mike and Gavin well I was I
was just just wondering about the
additional costs on particularly on
strike days
of accommodating people in hotels where
we heard from the earlier panel of
supplementary Summers that were being
paired to where replacement train
drivers is there an estimate of the
costs that the employees are incurring
in in in such additional expense I don't
have an estimate of the cost but
obviously the the reason why we do that
is to try and provide their service for
customers on these straight days so they
they're as a cost for that but there's
also an even bigger course of who went
to do that and the lost Revenue that we
would see so it's really important that
we try and provide as many services out
there limited as we can by using these
these staff to come out and do these
additional duties yeah and these would
often presumably be managers it was
previously done these roles in the past
April Donnelly yes yes and you're very
confident about the safety aspect there
of of using um
managers and others in these put in
these um positions yeah on those those
individuals have to be trained to a
certain standard and then on the day we
put additional people out to monitor to
make sure that the people are doing what
they're meant to do because obviously we
have to work with the officer they'll
regulator to make sure that we've got a
sensible a and safe method of operation
during strike days
I mean it's nice building that as well
because the comment was made here that
we reject that that not people who
aren't qualified have been used to run
student boxes just absolutely
manifesting not the case there's no
circumstance in which we'd allow that to
happen
um absolutely sure through assessment
and independent validation that our
managers that are working this
superpowers are confident and they've
done a super job uh but building on that
what I would say is that because they're
protected sort of critical National
infrastructure you know the the the the
supplies of freight to power stations
the some of the critical things you
think back to sort of June when we were
having these first discussions there's a
real concern around how Freight would
would uh be impacted and critical
National supplies
biomass to power stations is a
particular example and I'm very pleased
that actually it was it's a shame it was
necessary we have managed to make sure
those things run they've trained to have
run the critical National infrastructure
has been protected and so that's why
we've been investing in making sure that
managers can do that competently safely
if if there's instance on the railway
every day
um on strike and non-strike days they
all investigated the same way to the
same standard
um and and finally my point recognizing
that some of those managers perhaps
wouldn't have been in those posts for
some years
sometimes as I've worked to train one of
the reasons why we reduce the number of
trains on those days is so that managers
aren't under the same pressure and as a
normal member of Staff would be one of
the reasons why we thin the service out
a bit to make sure that actually they're
uh that they've had the ability over the
now 19 strike days to re-familitarize
themselves with those roles and become
not only competent but proficient in
dealing with situations that have
occurred and we've got a lot of evidence
that's been the case and those those
safety incidents would all be documented
absolutely yes and and I'm just thinking
back to Friday it was a non-strike day
when our child there was only two Trends
in the Northeast running
and the one I got was two and a half I
was lit thank you have you missed to get
the same an incident that occurs which
ended you know is investigated the
salmon strike data non-strike day
independently reviewed um and of course
the objective is always to understand
why so we can help people improve and
again that's the same whether there's a
strike or not
thank you no one to turn to the the role
of the government Mike and then Gavin
have some questions on that Mike
yes I mean this is this to you both and
I'll start with Tim
um first hello as well hello to you both
um as the new secretary of state and
rail Minister taken a different approach
to their predecessors in terms of the
negotiations or are they still throwing
a spanner in the works
well there was in a slightly different
position than the train companies
because as an armed length body we are
governed by the public sector pay
Arrangements
um but nevertheless we've throughout
this kept the department for transport
fully aware of the changes and the
proposals that we've been making and the
details their support has probably set
to pay guidelines required
um I think I have seen the the most
notable difference of course is that the
current sector of state and current row
Minister have met physically with the
Trade union leaders which didn't occur
before but other than that I can see no
difference because throughout this
process we have
um as I've said a number of times with
this committee you know there's enough
money in the railway to do what needs to
be done the challenge is to create
efficiency and do that safely so we
improve the service to passengers and
fight customers
so what we've done throughout this is to
identify the changes that we want to
make
this case maintenance particularly is
the area where we it was important to
save money to improve the reliability of
the Railway as well for the use of
Technology meaning we need less people
which was you know undoubtedly one of
the things at the beginning of the
district the rmt were concerned about
particularly
so we made the business case we
demonstrated to government that by
reducing 1 850 members of staff that
would provide a allow us to achieve the
savings we needed to make and would
provide a package for pay so we asked
government support and approval to make
that packet and that that was given back
in June we did it again in December and
again that was given in December for the
award that we made for the
um offer that we made in early December
so tone I hear uh but in terms of the
Practical process no the process hasn't
changed from my perspective
so you said there's a difference in tow
well notably quite obviously in so far
as the fact that the
um the current Secretary of State and
the current prime minister have met on a
number of occasions with the trade
unions directly that didn't occur before
that didn't that doesn't
um that didn't help me resolve the
disputes of the tssa or the or United
it's not preventing me to resolving the
distributes with r d
the trade unions the general secretaries
of the trade unions and the real
ministers now acting the role trying to
facilitate further discussions but
allowing the employer and the trade
unions to go in and try to understand
the areas of differences but ultimately
it's back to myself and tend to lead the
discussions with the Trade union and try
to get the you know the deal on the
table so yes there is greater engagement
um but we're at ultimately myself intent
to sort out
I mean you referred to closing tickets
in offices driverless trains at home
set of mums around terms of reference
seems to be driven by the DFT ultimately
ministers and yet by your own it
admittance you seem to be pretty
clueless how much that would save you
um the work's not been not been done and
yet the minister seem to be claiming
well that money that's where the money
will come from so is that putting a
spanner in the works is that a hindrance
or is that helpful well first of all
it's uh as myself that come up with
areas of reform rides in the industry
it's come up with areas of form in terms
of the financials of that what are
alluded to earlier on is we don't know
the final number because we don't know
how many booking office staff would be
repurposed on error roles
Etc so there is overall figures that
we've got but we cannot tie it down to a
final figure until we get through the
areas of reform we put a numbers against
different areas of reform you know we
talk about these large ticket items of
which is DC audio
Etc there's a lot of smaller areas of
before one that actually could generate
just a significant amounts of money as
dcodo and but we need to get we need to
get through with the trade unions and
try and resolve some of them and again
it's back to it's not about people
working longer it's about trying to get
greater efficiency within the hours that
we have people in the workplace and
that's just about tweaks and terms and
conditions not about wholesale throwing
everything out
moving on slightly
um well documented in fact the floor of
the house yesterday we had the statement
in terms of the Draconian legislation
um to effectively or try to ban strikes
that's what it is
um known as the minimum service levels
of agreement now the previous
Bill the previous impact assessment
actually
came back saying look actually this
would have aggregate matters with the
lead to further industrial strike for
further industrial action what's your
assessment I'll take it with you you
Steve first
until I see the legislation I have not
seen the detail of it and we've not been
privy to the what what it will really
mean in terms is that 30 40 50 minimum
service levels so if you've not seen
that detail so when the legislation if
the legislation goes through we will
then work with that once we understand
it but at the moment we don't have any
other of insight than what's been
announced
but
same position actually yes I mean there
is a difference between a minute power
and minimum service might be applied in
a signal box for example than a train
um because the signal box is either open
or shut it's binary whereas trains you
can have more fear of them so we need to
understand how legislation would apply
in those types of circumstances and we
haven't seen the detail yet to do that
we're on a safe Railway with this form
of provision in place and curtail in the
right for employees to withdraw their
labor
but we would only ever operate aside
forever if it's not safe we won't do it
what I can say is that um you know in
previous experience at much earlier in
my career nice but for your style it was
I saw a number of occasions in France
how not through legislation but through
the way the trade unions are structured
differently how very frequently when
their industrial action in France some
trained servers would run but not all of
it
and depending on which trade unions were
at work and which were not that was
quite a frequent I have to say event at
that particular time back in the 90s
um so I think perhaps caused by a
different thing whatever this the effect
was the same which was that some trains
ran and other trains didn't
um I've no reason to see why that in
itself creates an issue of safety
have you had any discussions with
ministers about this
I've not been involved in any
discussions didn't know minimum service
levels no no no discussions whatsoever
they've talked is that there was
legislation coming but not then the
detail of it in any way I don't know
thank you
okay thank you Gavin
um yes thanks very much chair um I have
a number of questions here but I
realized I'll trample over my college
question that 15 so I will refrain and
keep my permissions fairly tight
um if I could start this before on this
point just for clarity
um with something coming in terms of the
obviously the industrial action over the
past past months how much of the train
operating companies indemnified against
uh the the cost essentially of these
strikes
so the contracts are set out obviously
over the year depending what contract
you're on whether it's a national deal
contract that I'm urgency measures
agreement so you're measured over the
year you're giving a small a percentage
to operate the service and then there's
performance fees on the days that are
strikes then you would exclude that you
know David Bates excluded from the
performance days but then I'm still
measured over the other 300 NX days that
are that strikes are not happening on so
that's how it's measured and that's done
by an independent uh body at the end of
the year to evaluate how you've
delivered okay and I suppose a rough
percentage in in terms of the percentage
who meets the cost of this is it the DFT
and the taxpayers that talk in terms of
what percentage did the talks actually
meet in this or is it is
the taxpayer that pays for it
in terms of the cost of it in terms of
the staff solidies in terms of the loss
of Revenue that all sets with government
now under the when it removed obviously
from the franchising Arrangements into
the emergency emergence agreement in
their nrcs all the risk of cost and
revenue sits with government now that
was my understanding but thanks for for
putting that on on the record
um can I can ask this from a from a a
talk or RTG perspective you may have
heard that may ask the previous panel
which which is your take on a difference
in approach
to negotiations and disputes from the
Scottish government under other devolved
administrations and the UK government
I again I'm not involved in discussions
with these other government bodies I
don't deal with those charity colleagues
about them I again I don't I don't deal
with them I don't have an opinion on it
because I don't I don't have enough
knowledge of it if I'm perfectly honest
with you
okay obviously a former India of of
scotrail and you'll be obviously more
pretty or more aware of these situations
it's now nationalized obviously but um
but in general terms there's been many
others so just that the agreement the
security agreement that's now in places
made up of a percentage that's been
being paid by scotrail and that
percentage it's been made been paid by a
Scottish government of Transport
Scotland
um a government agency
there's a former MD of scotrail would
you agree that if Scott rails
significantly inflated track access
charges and were in line with the rest
of the UK area industry they'd be able
to pay more of that settlement from
their own and from their own resources I
I don't know if it's got able to track
accesses charges after I'd be perfectly
honest with you
um that's a matter for Scottish
government and with network rail I as
the chair of our DG don't not get
involved in that element of it I'm not
playing Pokemon yeah
um but this last question for uh the
point was made in the last
um
session about the the service that is
that is offered
um on strike data and the days sorry in
between strike days where we're by
um the network out with
um
the South Eastern perhaps the the Spain
of of Southern Central UK and what have
you it's largely either not get a
service at all or very very poor service
so I feel good Scotland and the northern
regions and what have you very poor this
year compared to other parts of the UK
why is that
it's a question it's been out a number
of times that the the approach to how
each area is going to be served it's
been driven by a number of things and
I've talked about critical Freight
routes for example I thought about
making sure that for every manager that
we have they can control the largest
possible area of the most critical
infrastructure so obviously you had a
key route between London and Scotland uh
and into Glasgow for example it was a
priority that's been open throughout
within Scotland itself for example them
my colleague Alex uh Heinz is
responsible for yeah so he's decided to
how to use the managers he's got to open
that Network that's not a that's not a
matter for uh Network rather rule that's
and locally decided the same words in my
region I've decided how best to use my
competent managers to protect the things
that are most important
typically the things that we've waited
on that for me as I said have been
critical national freight that has to be
moved and then where we're opening
passenger lines how we can move the
largest number of passengers with the
fewest number of managers and there's no
doubt that where you end up with
um more modern signaling installations
for example one person can control many
many miles of track because the
signaling runs largely automatically and
it's supervised whereas of course in
more rural locations typically sometimes
you know it requires one person to
require that just do five miles of track
and physically move points and move
signals so on that basis it's far yeah
you're going to open a much smaller part
of the Railway if you deploy your
managers to those locations it's all
been led by what's the right thing for
Freight and what's the right thing for
our passengers
okay I'm very conscious thank you Jason
thank you Paul thank you chair just to
build on my colleague and comments there
I mean if if you look
um in the Northeast we've seen some you
know massive disruption
um and then when Network rail strike
went on last week you know my
constituents were left without a single
Trend service you know why is it that
strikes in network rail of struck down
shut down local rail services in the
Northeast but haven't done so elsewhere
why is it as dramatic as that okay and
understood we apologize to all the
passengers that were inconvenienced by
that but I don't think there is a
difference the situation described in
the Northeast uh in some parts of
Scotland in some in my area in the
Northwest uh in in the South it's
exactly the same the the focus has been
on moving the largest number offering
service to the largest number of people
and the large number of freight
companies and that typically means the
main lines stay open but the the
secondary routes the routes that are
serving communities but perhaps not
having critical Freight in them are much
less likely to be opened and typically
on those uh local lines the the the the
number of signalers that's required to
operate each section of Route is much
much higher than on the main lines
um so so it's unfortunately it's a
function of uh that prioritization and
Freight passengers and getting as much
mileage opens we can for each person
that we have
okay I think there's a possibly another
consideration that it should be about
the criticality of the user as opposed
to the volume that you're putting
through but we're conscious of time as
well so I'll I'll push into a little bit
of a similar comment to to Steve in
terms of you know
they were going to shoot
um you know Sunderland station down
completely and then you had a local
outcry and all of a sudden it got
changed surely you should be in the best
place in the first place you shouldn't
need local Kickback to get to that
situation yeah I think this time alluded
to it's how do we try and serve the
masses and and and that is very very
difficult and there's a lot of decisions
have to be made again it's what
infrastructure can be made available
um as difficulty balance it you know I
do know that Network rail have done a
huge amount of work to try and get as
many signal boxes and can continue every
straight day to enhance the service and
it's just weirdly prioritized you know
and what with network real image here we
provide the best service so as a as a
bit of we'll try to do our base with it
and as I say Network railroad getting
more and more people starting to be
available at the open these areas
that you'll be tied on time but really
I'd like you to make sure you've got a
good look at what people need as opposed
to just the volume game but the one
point I do really want to put down from
the committee point of view when you
looked at the and you listened to the
first session you know there's some
quite robust discussions
um about the fact that the secretary of
state was actively blocking improvements
you know this was a DFT LED frustration
that was going on
um you know and that you were the end of
the rmt said the government will simply
not give a mandate you know to network
rail
do you recognize that
so the government has given a mandate to
did give a mandate to know about Rail
and and did again so in December
um so we have had mandate from from DFT
I I didn't need a new mandate does it
need something different to get no yes
no I think I think we the Mandate that
we have
is the one that I asked for is the one
that I can afford
um the as I've explained we know we've
funded this deal through
um I funded this deal through
efficiencies uh I I can't ask for a
mandate that I can't afford to pay so
you don't recognize government
interference as deliberately trying to
frustrate the deal which was the
implication from the first session it's
not been an issue from from that I've
had visibility of absolutely so I have
received a further Monday which will be
used to model in talking with the trade
unions but again for obvious reasons are
confidentiality that is something that I
can't talk about so I think you know
again as Tim says we have to put
proposals forward to government using
our expertise and areas reform that we
can then put forward a sensible proposal
which obviously ultimately government do
sign often give us the Mandate so but we
have got a revised mandate for this week
for tssc and rmt I could talk about yeah
thank you Jack you're on the very quick
subject yeah
just just relates to
um what we were saying a minute ago
about the service on strike days and
Stoke on Trent is another one of those
areas that doesn't have any service at
all on strike days I've had to drive on
a number of occasions to East Midlands
Parkway to get the train down uh to
London so are are you going to look more
at as Paul was saying about the actual
economic impact that that's having
obviously it's having severe economic
impact on those areas like Stoke
quadrante City without any services at
all on strike days could you please look
at
um and consider more the economic
impacts of of a lack of service on
strong days yes as a absolutely point
and I said earlier that it's Our
intention that you know hopefully there
won't be more strike days but if there
are more strike days we are certainly
going to
um we're working hard with our
colleagues to try and open more of the
network and see if we can run more
trains however you know if if opening
Stoke on Trent men closing somewhere
else then of course it's it's probably
one to pay the other and the assessment
we've made so far is that fellows
critical National fake flows for example
that that have a value to the whole
country those are the things that have
been leading our priorities
are either of you aware of of any other
country in Europe that's now suffered
eight months of travel destruction
because of an unresolved industrial
dispute on their railways
and we've heard that disputes have been
settled in Scotland
in Wales merseyside London why do you
think that uniquely
the bit of Railway in Europe that the UK
government is responsible for has not
been able to resolve an industrial
dispute
if I just take some of that I mean I
think we have been able to resolve some
industrial disputes with Unite with tssa
for the same grade group that we're
talking about here with the rmt and of
course for the managers back in the
summer so I think there has been
progress
um it's been a very difficult and
complex and of course I think so much of
this goes back to particularly covert in
the way that that every other country
and so is Scotland and so is Wales yeah
okay but if it's an infrastructure
perspective
um you know I think the thing that we're
clear on is we we needed to save some
money it was clear that the efficiency
of the Railway was that they're really
answering the question Mr Montgomery do
have a go at that
well I think the fact that again you
know just let's be fair Scotland did
suffer a large number of straight days
before it was resolved as well you know
so it's not been a it's not been a
simple process now what we've got to do
is how do we make this real with super
detective for the future how do we
economically protect it by making sure
that we work together with the trade
Unions that's a really important thing
is but what what's the Trade union is to
try and secure the long-term future of
the industry and the employees within
the industry and that's where we're
trying to move towards at this moment in
time why do you think the disputes have
been settled in in Scotland and Wales
and London and was decided not in
England again I think it's been
negotiation and compromise in both sides
and that's why they've got a a
settlement so we are still at that stage
of trying to get compromise and
settlement between ourselves and the
trade unions and we look I think you
know we we paint a picture that's a long
period of time none of us like to see
what's happening to customers can you
can you see that a sort of a
an ordinary member of the public looking
in on this and looking in on the fact
that this ongoing dispute that's still
not resolved is is a uniquely England
problem in the bits of England where the
Department of Transport are responsible
is going to reach the conclusion and
agree with the Union so this is a UK
government problem it's a problem with
government not with the unions
again you know as I can only talk about
the discussions that we have with the
trade unions it takes both teams to
operate together to try and get to the
solution you know whether it's UK
government or other government we have
to deal with what we've got in the in
front of us at this moment in time we
are working with the trade unions to try
and get a resolvement in this but it
does take both sides we cannot you know
and we have to ensure that we can
continue to make sure that they're
always sustainable for the future and
that means that both sides of Trade
union management trying to thrash out a
sensible deal that we can then obviously
give our employees up here increase at
the end of but how do we make the
railway more sustainable for customers
for the future as well as everybody else
and put a figure on on how much the
government will have to reimburse you
for losses on strike days
we don't receive any payment for losses
on strike debt for the amount for you
you're indemnified aren't you for the
cost of the strike by the government so
government have a revenue with them and
have cost with them so the operator as
in each of the train operating companies
does not own that own the cost of the
revenue so what is that figure do you
know what that figure is it a lot of
Revenue in the day or it varies I don't
have the exact figure for you but
totally you have no idea what the token
is a very kind of headline if I couldn't
give you an exact figure I think one of
the unions wrote To Us suggesting it was
318 million so far over the older
straight days that that number will be
quite High yeah being that region 300 to
500 we would it's quite a sizeable
amount of money that might have gone to
help resolve this dispute in terms of
offering the the workers a better deal
isn't it
but I mean that lost Revenue isn't the
same as increased costs obviously so and
it's a tragedy to lose the revenue but
of course that's money that hasn't come
into the industry whereas obviously the
increase of the money that the taxpayer
is having to Fork out
because of the government's failure to
reach a deal with you with the unions is
money that could have been put into that
offer and resolved this dispute months
ago
as I say you know I think we have to
come back to the situation of where we
we started this whole process that the
industry is only 80 of the revenue that
it had previously yeah it's got 100 of
the costs yes so how do we work together
with the trade unions to try and ensure
that we can reduce some of the cost to
the industry and then regrow the revenue
back and I think that's the challenge
was you know the I think we've got to be
clear the industry over the last 20
years has grown and grown you know
there's more people employed within the
real industry in the UK there's greater
revenues but the pandemic as you said
affected every day all businesses we're
looking at a railway how do we start to
grow that back now but we have to take
measures to self-help because we can't
keep taking taxpayers money all the time
because we know the pressures on the
other sectors so it's how do we work
with the trade unions to try and Achieve
that savings within the cost numbers and
then allows to grow forward as just say
my own opinion has been in the industry
for a long time we have seen Peaks and
troughs yes I said honey extremely
difficult and different situation will
experience but the industry does come
back again and we can grow passenger
numbers
okay thank you very much for your time
this morning
um appreciate there's a lot still going
on and I hope that the ongoing
negotiations will come to satisfactory
conclusion thank you thank you